know what we do we come up they walk
every day just to the end of their drive
to get some fresh air
75 year old Michael is fragile and has a
string of serious medical conditions
we'll only go twice today yeah well done
well done
until recently his wife Elaine had help
looking after him but she's terrified by
the spread of coronavirus fueled by
fears carers are not getting the
protective equipment they need
she's now refusing to let them into the
house then you've got any aprons then
got the gloves it was too risky - to
know that I was unsure who they were
mixing with I couldn't have the family
and so I had to make a decision that no
nobody would come in the house so that I
could keep Michael totally safe Oh
Michael has recently developed problems
with his feet he's already got dementia
prostate cancer a kidney tumor and is
showing signs of Parkinson's it's a lot
for one person to cope with sometimes
I'll sit in a bath and I'll cry Michael
can't take on board if I cry just know
what to do if I cry but I think I can't
take this anymore I can't go on
Michael used to attend Glamis hall day
center in Northampton share its staff
are now helping in the community and say
they understand Elaine's fears as we
know her virus takes no prisoners and
you could potentially unwillingly take
it from one household to another Allie
is delivering a hot meal to 91 year old
layers who used to attend the day center
five days a week he can't cook for
himself going house-to-house in this way
is a risk Ali says she has to take I
couldn't not bring less his lunch today
because I don't have a face mask the job
still needs doing regardless and les is
very grateful
barbarous Elaine's husband Michael also
understands the kindness being shown to
him you've got a lovely wife haven't you
I've got the best the bestest of course
if it wasn't for a lion I wouldn't be a
announced fairy Gordon's what you
normally say oh my angel this is a
different kind of frontline where big
sacrifices and acts of heroism are also
taking place Lisa Holland Sky News
Northamptonshire